I forgot my gun boy get on the ground
right now get on the ground right now
drop the knife drop the knife an
officer-involved shooting is now under
investigation in Florida after a suspect
allegedly robbed an elderly woman and
later approached an officer with what
appeared to be a knife
on the ground get on the ground it
happened on Tuesday November 15th in
Sarasota Florida just after 10 o'clock
that morning an 83 year old woman
reported a robbery at a grocery store
she says she was unloading groceries
into her car when a suspect approached
her and tried to grab the purse off her
shoulder she says the man had something
shiny in his hand and threatened her
with it at the same time another man in
the parking lot saw what was happening
and tried to help the woman he pulled
out his phone and took a video of the
suspect before calling 9-1-1 officials
determined the suspect to be a 71 year
old man from Sarasota seven to four he's
running towards the Homewood Suites
investigators tracked the suspect down
to a nearby Hotel a responding officer
found him standing between two vehicles
in the parking lot get on the ground
right now get on the ground right now
body camera video shows the officer
calling out to the suspect asking him to
drop the weapon when the suspect refuses
and takes a few steps forward the
officer opens fire drop the knife
subject to upset that I've dropped the
knife the suspect was taken to Sarasota
Memorial Hospital and is now in stable
condition
[Music]
the involved officer was not injured in
the incident he has since been placed on
paid administrative leave from here the
Florida Department of Law Enforcement
will investigate the shooting the
Sarasota Police Department criminal
investigation division is investigating
the armed robbery the suspect now faces
charges of aggravated assault with a
weapon without intent to kill an armed
robbery for the latest developments in
this case and all things True Crime stay
with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie